this episode is brought to you by tab
for a cause a free Chrome extension that
helps you raise money for causes you
care about just by browsing the web
every time you open a new tab they make
a donation to a charity of your choice
if you'd like to help install the free
extension using the link below
[Music]
for well over half a century the United
States has enjoyed its status as the
world's strongest superpower and awarded
itself the title of defender of global
democracy many Americans see their
country as the world's moral arbiter the
shining city on a hill the standard by
which all other nations should judge
themselves the reasoning for this
superiority complex mostly boils down to
the notion that US citizens enjoy the
purest most untainted Democratic
experience the world has to offer free
and fair elections equal representation
universal rights and countless other
indicators of a healthy and thriving
democracy for an action is often seen as
a threat to our democracy manipulated
news is considered extremely dangerous
to our democracy and elections are
steeped in the language of democracy
versus tyranny the u.s. is obsessed with
the idea of democracy but if you dig a
little deeper you'll find some worrying
trends in this episode we're going to
discuss what it means to be a democratic
nation and take a look at some data that
suggests the u.s. is not living up to
the standards it sets for the rest of
the world before we begin we need to get
one thing out of the way there are
plenty of people who will say well
actually the u.s. is a republic not a
democracy and then everyone starts
yelling and suddenly no one remembers
what we were talking about in the first
place I'll try to make this quick the
definition of democracy is a system of
government by the whole population or
all the eligible members of a state
typically through elected
representatives the definition of
Republic is a state in which supreme
power is held by the people and their
elected representatives and which has an
elected or nominated president rather
than a monarch you can see why people
can get a bit confused to make a long
story short Americans have been arguing
about whether the country is a republic
or a democracy since the very founding
of the nation and that probably won't
change anytime soon the best consensus
we can reach is that the United States
can be classified as a democratic
republic for a representative democracy
our system of governance has
characteristics of both Republic and
democracy people who claim otherwise are
generally just out to derail the
conversation in this video we'll be
discussing the aspect of American life
which are supposed to be democratic
things like voting and elections the
main goal here is not to determine
whether the u.s. is a democracy in the
Republic vs. democracy sense but whether
the nation lives up to the standards it
supposedly represents and by which we
judge the rest of the world let's start
with a brief look at the nation as a
whole
what is it what does it represent the
u.s. is the richest nation in human
history home to some of the very
wealthiest people on the planet it's
also a nation of crushing inequality the
richest three people own more wealth
than the bottom 160 million Americans
and Jeff Bezos founder of Amazon and the
richest man on earth
makes more money in one minute than the
average American household earns in
almost two years the u.s. is home to the
world's most powerful military by far we
spend more money on our military than
the next ten highest spenders combined
in theory this massive force is purely
for national defense but the country has
proven that it's more than happy to use
military action to establish regimes
more amenable to US interests for
example we've instigated or supported no
fewer than 56 coos in Latin America
since the 1950s not to mention the
Middle East
often toppling democratically elected
governments this is in stark contrast to
our nation's preferred image as the
defender of global democracy
geographically the u.s. is prime real
estate as Otto von Bismarck once put it
the Americans are a lucky people they're
bordered to the north and south by weak
neighbors and to the east and west by
FISH this geographical luxury has
allowed the nation to flourish
unbothered by the goings-on of other
countries and able to spend its money
not rebuilding after the world wars like
european nations but in other areas
strengthening its military to become the
sole world superpower and establishing
massive international corporations and
yet with all this wealth and superb
geopolitical positioning the u.s. still
fails in several key metrics some 40
million of its people live in poverty
with another 10 million right on the
brink American health care is
consistently rated the worst in the
developed world with thousands dying or
going bankrupt every year thanks to the
extraordinarily expensive system in 2018
America was added to the list of most
dangerous nations in which to be a
journalist and that was before the
targeting of journalists by police in
the wake of the murder of George Floyd
these should all be red flags on their
own but if we're talking specifically
about democracy we need to look at more
testable areas of civic life for the
rest of this video I'll be drawing some
data from a report titled testing
theories of American politics elites
interest groups and average citizens
which was published in 2014 in the
journal perspectives on politics you can
find a link to the study in the
description in this report the off
set out to test for theories of American
political power essentially trying to
measure who's voice matters in American
politics these four theories are
majoritarian electoral democracy
economic elite domination and two types
of interest group pluralism majoritarian
pluralism and biased pluralism to put it
in slightly easier language the groups
are average citizens the wealthy and
powerful and large organized groups
either popular or business oriented in
the ideal vision of the country many
Americans would want the balance to be
skewed towards average citizens and
popular mass movements as domination by
the economic elites or business
interests would indicate less of a
democracy and more of a plutocracy or
oligarchy that is ruled by a minority of
wealthy players if you polled a sample
of Americans about what they think the
ideal form of democracy would be odds
are the vast majority would say
one-person one-vote everyone's interests
are given the same weight a large
portion of the American population
believes that we already experienced
this ideal form of democracy the authors
of the report come to a very different
conclusion over the course of their
testing by pitting the four dominant
theories of American political power
against one another using a data set
consisting of nearly 2000 policy issues
they reached the exact opposite
conclusion they state we have been able
to produce some striking findings one is
the nearly total failure of median voter
and other majoritarian electoral
democracy theories when the Preferences
of economic elites and the stands of
organized interest groups are controlled
for the Preferences of the average
American appear to have only a minuscule
near zero statistically non significant
impact on public policy they go on to
say interest groups do have substantial
independent impacts on policy and a few
groups particularly labor unions
represent average citizens views
reasonably well but the interest group
system as a whole does not overall net
interest group alignments are not
significantly related to the Preferences
of average citizens the net alignments
of the most influential business
oriented groups are negatively related
to the average citizens wishes so not
only our business interest not in
alignment with the will of the voting
majority they are directly opposed to it
this should not come as a surprise when
extremely wealthy individuals and
corporations are allowed to dump as much
money as they want into politics it
would stand to reason that their desires
hold more weight to those receiving the
contributions these graphs from the
study sum up the findings pretty well
regardless of average voter desire for
legislation on any given issue the odds
of Representatives delivering the
desired result is the same contrary to
this we see a strong correlation between
economic elite and special interest
desires and legislative action this
should be alarming because if our votes
are meaningless then we don't actually
have any say in how the country is run
that would mean our system is not
democratic okay but if our votes are
meaningless why do politicians try so
hard to convince people to vote for them
well think of the optics without a
significant number of votes from the
population the country would not be
considered Democratic at all the
illusion of the shining city on a hill
would be shattered and the decidedly
undemocratic oligarchy laid bare for the
rest of the world to see so those votes
from average citizens are crucial but by
actively seeking votes and encouraging
voting politicians open themselves up to
the undesirable possibility of being
voted out if only there were some way to
ensure that vote totals from states
would always deliver the desired outcome
enter gerrymandering has a quick crash
course on state level politics each
state is divided up into voting
districts of similar population sizes to
facilitate the process of voting and
establish a number of seats to be filled
by representatives make sense but what
doesn't make a whole lot of sense from a
Democratic standpoint is how these
districts are drawn in America much to
the bafflement of foreign politicians
those currently in elected positions get
to draw their own district maps think
about that for a second in a democracy
the citizens should be able to vote for
the representative of their choice what
we have is the opposite representatives
get to choose their voters they can draw
maps that exclude certain populations or
pack in as many of a certain type of
voter as possible that's part of the
reason district maps often look so
strange
they've been carefully crafted to
deliver the desired result think what
you will of John Oliver he's got a
pretty good episode on gerrymandering
here's a useful explainer from the show
The Washington Post showed how this can
work
look at this hypothetical state it's 60%
blue voters 40% red and it needs to be
carved up into five districts now
proportionally you would want three blue
and two red districts but if you draw
the lines like this you can get three
red majorities and two
blues and if you draw it like this you
can get five blue majorities and no red
and if you draw lines like this it looks
like a dick which is and before you go
calling me a partisan hack I'm opposed
to gerrymandering from both parties and
you should be too both Democrats and
Republicans do it and while it's
technically not illegal it should be
it gives politicians tremendous control
over the outcome of elections and that
should not be acceptable in a healthy
democracy but perhaps even more
egregious than gerrymandering is
outright voter suppression there is no
right more fundamental to democracy than
the right to vote it's always been in
the interest of some politicians to
dissuade certain voting blocks from
casting their ballots or to make it more
difficult for them to do so but in
recent years voter suppression has
reached levels that would cast doubt on
the legitimacy of our elections if they
were to take place in any other country
repressive voter ID laws voter roll
purges gerrymandering is also a form of
voter suppression but at least those
responsible for questionable district
maps can hide behind the technical
legality of their actions what we're
seeing out on the voting trail is much
more alarming instead of going to all
the effort of trying to convince people
not to vote those in power have taken to
simply closing polling locations so
voters don't even have the opportunity
this has been a widespread problem in
recent years and it's finally starting
to get the attention it deserves
take the Kentucky primary on June 23rd
in a normal election year Kentucky would
have over 3700 polling stations
available this time around they slashed
that number to under 200 nearly half of
Kentucky's black voters live in a single
County Jefferson County had just one
polling station one polling station for
over three quarters of a million
residents this will lead to multi-hour
wait times that most voters simply won't
be able to manage people have to work
and if the wait is eight hours long
which is becoming more and more common
the majority of voters won't be able to
cast their ballot the practice of
closing polling locations is
particularly insidious because those
doing the closing can say look everyone
had the opportunity to vote there was a
polling station open but in reality if
you can't afford to wait in line for an
entire day you do not have the
opportunity to vote what those in power
are doing is making it impossible for
the people to make their voices heard
they are denying Americans their most
fundamental democratic rights
at what point do we have to admit that
our elections are illegitimate and
undemocratic we're not shy about
stepping in when other countries conduct
fraudulent elections so why should we
get a free pass to return to the study
we discussed earlier in their conclusion
the author's state what do our findings
say about democracy in America they
certainly constitute troubling news for
advocates of populistic democracy who
want their governments to respond
primarily or exclusively to the policy
preferences of their citizens in the
United States our findings indicate the
majority does not rule at least not in
the causal sense of actually determining
policy outcomes when a majority of
citizens disagrees with the economic
elites or with organized interests they
generally lose moreover because of the
strong status quo bias built into the US
political system even when fairly large
majorities of Americans favor policy
change they generally do not get it they
end by saying we believe that if
policymaking is dominated by powerful
business organizations and a small
number of affluent Americans then
America's claims to being a democratic
society are seriously threatened and
they're absolutely right in fact I'd go
even further and say that the United
States is no longer a democracy if our
districts are gerrymander to all but
ensure a certain outcome if our polling
stations are closed making it impossible
for us to vote if the desires of average
voters are disregarded even with an
overwhelming majority if corporations
and the ultra wealthy can simply buy
their desired legislation we're not
living in a democracy we're living under
an oligarchy the thing we need to
realize is that this is not some
unfortunate and unforeseeable outcome
this is the system functioning as
intended at least as intended since the
1980s crippling precarity for the many
to build the ever-growing affluence of
the few with no way to challenge the
status quo by electoral means crumbling
infrastructure juxtaposed with
glistening new corporate campuses and
headquarters tens of millions of
Americans laid off during a global
pandemic while the richest handful of
people become even richer and the stock
market hums along nicely we need to come
to grips with the fact that there has
been a consensus in American politics
for decades now the Democrats and
Republicans represent two wings of the
same party dedicated to maintaining
corporate dominance ask yourself whose
voice matters in American politics whose
desires are taken into consideration our
tax laws benefit the rich our
environmental laws benefit corporations
you
ian's have been gutted and all but
destroyed to remove workers bargaining
power our news networks are owned by the
rich and politically-connected our
health care system is a massive
for-profit industry that turns human
suffering into giant checks for
politicians and all the while the two
major parties put on a bit of political
theater slandering each other as the
ultimate evil when their economic
interest aligned on just about every
issue they trade places every few years
voters feel vindicated and disappointed
then vindicated again as their preferred
party goes through the motions
with one hand behind their back reaching
for corporate donations in a true
representative democracy the will of the
people would matter our votes would
matter you don't have to look very hard
to see that isn't the case the United
States should not be considered a
representative democracy if you'd like
to help make a difference in the lives
of others consider installing the tab
for a cause Chrome extension it's
completely free and it lets you
contribute to things you care about just
by browsing the web which you're already
doing anyway you can help fund new
schools provide clean water protect the
environment and more tab for a cause
puts a couple of small ads on each new
tab you open and then donates that money
to the charity of your choice it takes
less than 30 seconds to add the
extension to your browser and you can
start making a difference right now
install tab for a Cause by visiting tab
gladly do slash second thought if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more like it consider subscribing to
stay up to date with my latest episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down and if you really want to
help support my channel I recently
started a patreon which you can find at
patreon.com slash second thought you can
check out my previous episodes by
clicking the links on your screen thanks
for watching and I'll see you next week